gestern hat innenminister horst seehofer
ein verbot ausgesprochen gegen die
terrororganisation hisbollah auf die
reaktionen sind wir gespannt darüber
wollen wir jetzt sprechen mit meinem
kollegen max kiewel er ist bei bild
terrorexperte mag es gab es denn schon
erste reaktionen auf dieses verbot ja
wer reagiert hat ist das regime im iran
dafür muss man wissen der iran lenkt
steuert finanziert die hisbollah nutzt
sie für anschläge auf der ganzen welt
und dort hat sich heute morgen das
außenministerium erklärt hat gesagt
diese entscheidung der deutschen
regierung gegen die scolari rational und
eine respektlosigkeit gegenüber dem iran
und der libanesischen regierung also
dort erwartungsgemäß kritik an der
deutschen entscheidung
das war zu erwarten hat sich denn auch
die hisbollah selbst schon geäußert also
dieses bull hat offiziell noch nichts
dazu gesagt aber dieses ball hat
natürlich leute im umfeld die in solchen
situationen für sie sprechen
wir hatten die möglichkeit mit einem
dieser männer zu sprechen er heiße phase
la plata war selbst jahrelang hisbollah
mitglied hat beziehungen zum
führungszirkel und tritt eigentlich in
der öffentlichkeit in den
fernsehsendungen auf um die position der
hisbollah zu erklären und zu zu zu
transportieren und wir hatten gestern
die möglichkeit mit ihm zu sprechen
ihre anhänger stehen für hass auf
amerika hass auf israel hass auf den
westen in der libanesischen hauptstadt
beirut hat die hisbollah ihrem
hauptstützpunkt über mittelsmänner
gelingt es uns kontakt zur führung der
islamisten herzustellen
omonia ich habe diese botschaft an die
deutsche regierung nimmt diese
entscheidung zurück die entscheidung ist
gegenüber den hisbollah aktivisten in
deutschland ungerechtfertigt deutschland
sollte sich entschuldigen so wie es dem
demokratischen system in deutschland
entspricht
der schritt der deutschen regierung sehr
bedauerlich auch war deutschland
eigentlich gute beziehungen zur
libanesischen hisbollah unterhalten hat
und zum beispiel bei der geisel
verhandlungen zwischen dem libanesischen
widerstand und dem israelischen feind
vermittelt hat der schrittes
überraschend und absolut
ungerechtfertigt
hisbollah ist keine terrororganisation
hisbollah ist eine politische partei und
die escola repräsentiert den widerstand
gegen den israelischen feind
ich glaube nicht dass diese entscheidung
auswirkungen auf die finanzen der
hisbollah hat denn diesmal wird aus dem
iran finanziert aber in der
vergangenheit haben viele abgeordnete
deutschland offiziell besucht und
vorträge gehalten ich weiß wirklich
nicht warum die deutschen jetzt ihr
denken geändert haben die hisbollah das
sagt aktivist ab das dann noch werde
nicht spontan handeln sondern nun in
aller ruhe überlegen wie es auf die
deutsche entscheidung reagieren wird wir
haben es gerade gesehen hier wurde ja
eine entschuldigung von deutschland
gefordert max wie ordnete diese
antworten ein ja das ist natürlich die
gleiche propaganda die gleichen lügen
muss man sagen wie man sie von der
hisbollah seit jahrzehnten hört und
kennt es wird immer vom israelischen
feind gesprochen man selbst nennt sich
den libanesischen widerstand was nicht
erwähnt wird dass man den letzten
jahrzehnten synagogen in die luft
gesprengt hat gemeindehäuser in die luft
gesprengt hat dass heute mehr als 100000
raketen auf israel zielen und ja das
sind eben die lügen und propaganda und
das was jetzt in deutschland verboten
wurde
vielen herzlichen dank für deine
einschätzung